[Musik]
der sound der alpen jauchzen und jodeln
haben hier tradition für erika stucki
ist der yotla vor allem eins ein ausruf
von lebenslust
[Musik]
blk stucki ist seit vielen jahren eine
bekannte juden künstlerin in der
schweizer musikszene
das echo der alpen ist ihre inspiration
[Musik]
natürlich trends ganz anders hier aus
wenn ich in texas im staub okay das eis
des alex gebiets hat erika stucki
unzählige male gestiegen um den größten
gletscher der schweiz ranken sich mythen
es sind die geister geschichten ihrer
kindheit geboren wurde erika stucki in
den usa in den 1960 er jahren dass ihre
eltern später beschlossen in ein kleines
schweizer bergdorf zu ziehen war ein
schock für sie
[Musik]
zwei wurzeln doppelte heimat aus diesem
kulturmix entsteht erika stuckis musik
auf der bühne hat sie viele rollen
moderne heidi freches kauka
[Musik]
jubel mischt sie nicht nur mit
rock'n'roll auch mit blues es ist
erstaunlich wie nahe die 2 jean oder
gesangs arten sich sind beides weiter
sehr nahe beim gebetssaal beim weinen
beim klagen nur die vielen faktoren ab
sie seien ein wunderschönes beten
jammern
[Musik]
ttt
klagelied warnung oder lockruf für das
vieh mit einem jodler kommunizierten
früher die bergleute von einer einem zu
anderen erika stucki interpretiert den
traditionellen volksbrauch ganz modern
[Musik]
das für millionen ist eigentlich keine
hexerei wenn du das mit der kopfstimme
begriffen hast dass du
das so kippen lassen kannst
und dann noch die tunneltechnik
schweizer und us amerikanischer heimat
sound die jodlerin erika stucki
[Musik]